Speaker 1: o talk about William Barr again today,
I know we've we've talked about him already
this week. William Barr has a new book. William
Barr is Donald Trump's former attorney general,
and in the book, Barr makes all sorts of explosive
claims, and he's been doing some interesting
interviews. Now I want to make sure my position
on Barr is clear. I believe his stories are all
true. I don't think William Barr is making up
the stories that he tells about Donald Trump,
and we're going to listen to another completely
wacky one in a moment. That being said,
I see Barr as just as much of a problem as all
of these other Trumpian clowns. And Barr even
said yesterday that despite all of the stuff that
Trump did, that Barr finds completely disgusting
he would still vote for Trump over a Democrat
in 2024 if Trump were the nominee. So the guy
is still despicable. He's just trying to sell
a book. But I do think he's telling the truth,
and you have to hear the story that he told
Bret Baier yesterday on Fox News. Barr describes
a completely detached from reality Trump, who
in the aftermath of the 2020 election, when it
was obvious to anybody with common sense that Joe
Biden won and that Joe Biden would be President.
Trump, according to Barr, genuinely believed he
was going to be president for another four years.
And we've said before, does did Trump believe
this stuff or was it just a grift? And by the end,
it didn't really matter because Trump was
still fundraising on the basis that he was
going to fight the results and whatever. It didn't
really matter whether Trump believed it or not.
But according to what Bartels, Bret Baer,
Trump really did believe he had won and
that he would somehow take the White House
from Joe Biden listen to this morning were
Speaker 2: unsettling moment
for you in the administration.
It was certainly unsettling when I went in to
talk to the president about the election, and,
you know, he was livid and shaking and, you
know, showed a lot of temper shaking and yelling.
That was a little unsettling. But the other
thing that was actually unsettling is later,
when I went in to actually give
him my letter of resignation,
he started talking about how he had actually won
the election and how the machines were rigged
and that he was actually going to be there for
another term. And he was very confident of that.
And I just felt this showed a detachment
from reality that was stunning to
Speaker 1: completely disconnected from reality.
I mean, what? Again, I believe bar and what Bar
describes there is a very delusional
person and any person thinking through
the events of the Trump administration in
understanding what William Barr is saying.
Trump believed he won, and he believed he
would somehow end up spending four more years
in the White House if he was that detached
from reality about something so basic about
the election's over. Biden won. Biden's going
to be the president. You're going to leave,
you're going to leave either bye bye. You're
under your power or that of someone dragging
you out. If he was that disconnected from reality
about something so simple as how elections work,
what else was going on where Trump simply didn't
understand the nuts and bolts of what he was
involved in? And of course, we have to assume the
Putin conversations, the North Korea negotiations,
all of these different things. When we hear
Trump asked whether you could you could nuke a
hurricane, well, he's just that disconnected
from reality. That's how sick he is now.
William Barr is no hero, as I told you
yesterday, even despite all this. William Barr
still told Savannah Guthrie she'd
still choose Trump over a Democrat,
and that's why we have to
remember these people are like
98 percent in the cult rather than 100 percent.
Speaker 4: You say in your book, it's time for the
party to move on from Trump. Liz Cheney has said
he is not fit to serve and should not be ever near
the Oval Office again. Do you agree with that?
Speaker 2: Well, I certainly have made it
clear I don't think he should be our
nominee, and I'm going to, you know,
support somebody else for the nomination if
Speaker 4: he is the nominee. And you have
your choice is Donald Trump or whoever is running
on the Democratic side, would you vote for him?
Speaker 2: Because I believe that
the greatest threat to the country
is the progressive agenda being pushed by the
Democratic Party. It's inconceivable to me that
I wouldn't vote for the Republican nominee.
Speaker 4: So, David, if he lied about the
election and threatened democracy, as you write
in your book. Well, it's better than a Democrat.
Speaker 2: It's hard to project what the facts
are going to turn out to be three years hence.
But as of now, it's hard for me to concede that
I wouldn't vote for the Republican nominee.
Speaker 1: A threat to democracy, you say, and
you're a threat to democracy unfit to serve.
Delusional detachment from reality. And yet I
would still vote for the guy because it's better
than a Democrat just as a couple of reminders. And
I know some of you have seen these clips already.
Here is Barr saying he told Trump. All
the election stuff you're saying is
Speaker 2: B.S. and I told him that all this stuff
was bull and about election fraud. And you know,
it's wrong to be shoveling it out the way his team
wants. And he started asking me about different
theories and I have the answers. I was able
to tell them, this is wrong because of this,
you're trying to set him straight. Yes. And you
know, he listened. He he he was obviously getting
very angry about this. I said, OK, well, look, I
understand you're upset with me and I'm perfectly
happy to tender my resignation. And then, Oh,
he's left to the desk and he slapped the desk
and he said, accepted. Accept it and then boom,
he slapped it again. Accept it. Go home. Don't
go back to your office. Go home. You're done.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And lastly, also Bill Barr
describing the clown show of lawyers. But he
would still vote for Trump over a Democrat guys
Speaker 2: and about election fraud. And you
know, it's wrong to be shoveling it out the
way his team wants. And then he also told Trump
what he thought of his legal team. Not a lot.
I said the reason you are where you are is because
you wheeled out a clown show of lawyers, a clown
show. Yeah, clown car or something like that. I
said, it's just a bunch of clowns. Who were you
referring to? Rudy Giuliani's crackerjack legal
team, among others, Barr says the president shot
back listing the ways he said Barr had failed him.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so anyway, he'd still vote. So,
so I believe every single one of these stories
I do. But Bah is not had some kind of awakening
back to common sense or whatever. At the end
of the day, if it's Trump versus, it sounds
like any Democrat. Despite the dangers that Barr
has associated Trump with danger to democracy,
unfettered all the stuff, he'd still vote
Trump. And that's why it's just a reminder
these are not people we can count on to help
us do anything. Anything, anything, anything.